all right now let's get labor's take on
things this morning from shadow home
secretary yvette cooper good morning
shadow home secretary
good morning trevor
now last week on this program
your colleague jonathan reynolds said
that sanctions on russia have had a
significant effect um
oddly enough the ruble is now worth more
than it was before the invasion
do you think that we need to do more
than is currently being
proposed by government we just heard
from kit malthouse
we do support stronger action we support
the action that the government has taken
to provide military support for ukraine
to be able to defend itself and to
continue to do so and we also support
strong sanctions and we think we need to
be continually looking at where further
we can go to put maximum economic
pressure
on russia and on putin's government that
includes looking at individual sanctions
that also includes
looking more widely but we also need to
do this in a united way across not just
europe but across the world because i
think it's been that united front that
has been really important in
addressing this
really cruel and vile illegal war from
putin
are you worried that the united front is
essentially being punctured a bit by the
german reluctance to
stop gas we understand how difficult it
is for them but
it's not as difficult as it is for the
ukrainian people is it
obviously it's hugely difficult for the
ukrainian people and they have shown
incredible bravery in the response uh to
this illegal invasion as well and also
in response to war crimes that are
taking place and the terrible
bombardment so that's why we do yes urge
germany and other countries to really
all work together to try and reduce that
dependency on
russian oil and gas and to actually have
alternatives because this is obviously a
part of a broader sanctions approach we
have to have the strongest possible
action to put the pressure on
there are things that we can do
ourselves and i want to come to the
issue of refugees in a moment which is
your uh
portfolio but on the question of weapons
um prime minister's offering
more a fresh delivery of weapons to the
to ukraine
yesterday
um do you think that we are doing enough
on the military and uh the weapons end
of things
well we support the action the
government's taken on this and i think
this is an important area as you say
there are huge differences between us
and the government on the support for
refugees where we don't think the
government's gone far enough but we
actually support the government on the
action that they've taken to provide
military support for ukraine and it's
good i think that we've got that cross
party agreement on that and we're going
to have to continue to do so because
this doesn't look like this is coming to
a quick end uh it's important that some
of russia's objectives have been
frustrated by the bravery of what
ukraine has been doing but we also know
that they are continuing this really
horrendous bombardment and we've seen
obviously the cases of torture as well
but i think the issue around the
refugees visas is really important it is
shocking it is just truly shameful the
long delays that we have in getting
ukrainian families visas to come stay
with british families who want to host
and support them 30 000 people are
waiting for visas around half of them
have been waiting for more than 10 days
many of them have been waiting for two
for three weeks now
and having filled in all of the forms
this is just disgraceful delays and i do
not understand why prissy patel is so
failing to get a grip on this
well uh whatever they're doing one
simple way of cutting through this would
simply be to drop the visa requirement
as has been the case in uh countries on
the continent would labor support the
removal of the visa requirement
for ukrainian uh asylum seekers
essentially
we think you should drop the extra
bureaucracy you can simply do
suggestions i'm asking specifically
about the visa requirement
yeah
so
so we described a kind of emergency visa
which is effectively just the security
checks that's what we need to do you
don't need a lot of this additional visa
requirements for example to come on the
homes for ukraine scheme ukrainian
families are supposed to prove their
residence as to where they were living
before the 1st of january so people are
uploading utility bills or other kinds
of details that then has to be checked
by caseworkers that then adds to delays
the point about security checks is
ministers and officials have themselves
admitted you can do them on the spot you
can do them within a matter of hours so
there is absolutely no excuse for these
weeks of delays we should be able to
just do this and grant people permission
to come pretty much instantly and get
those checks done straight away
so to be clear
an emergency visa is still a visa but
you
would only apply
one test
which you think could be passed within
hours about whether somebody's a
security risk or not
do you really think believe that yes
how would you know with the minister how
would you know somebody says
i'm i'm not a russian i'm not a member
of the wagner group i'm not coming to us
how would we actually be able to know
that within hours
these are the standard security checks
that we already do um sort of standard
checks with with passports and so on and
ministers and officials have themselves
said they've themselves said that
security checks can be done online
they've themselves said these security
checks can be done either on the spot
you're effectively checking somebody
against a database of wanted criminals
you're you're checking people in that
respect so those are the kinds of checks
that you can do really quickly and
ministers and officials have both
admitted that they can do them really
quickly that's not what's holding things
up it's not the security checks it's the
fact that they've added huge amounts of
bureaucracy that they've never got a
grip of this and bear in mind the home
office had the opportunity to prepare
they had months to prepare for this it's
six weeks ago we were urging them to
take action and they haven't done so
pretty patel wanted to simply use the
existing visa system you remember we had
that awful moment when a home office
minister effectively was saying people
should get a seasonal workers visa
perhaps to come and pick fruit they
tried not to set up a proper scheme and
then when they did do so they added huge
amounts of bureaucracy to it but it's
letting everyone down you have disabled
disabled man for example who can't leave
ukraine until he's got his full visa in
a case that i know of you have moms and
kids who are running out of money and it
is shameful british people want to be
generous and want to provide support and
pretty patel is not letting them
okay forgive me for for hiring you up
but uh we do need to talk about domestic
politics a bit one question uh or maybe
a couple questions on on this um
your
former shadow chancellor john mcdonnell
said in 2019 uh in the manifesto
actually that you fought on that labour
would scrap non-dom status altogether uh
is the future labor government still
going to do that
well rachel's rachel reeves has set up a
review of all
those sorts of tax exemptions and tax
arrangements and that is underway at the
moment but look there is a clear issue
at the moment which is why you're asking
the question about rishi sunak's
household tax arrangements at a time
when he has been putting taxes up for
everyone asking everybody else to pay
over a thousand pounds more
his household has had special tax
arrangements that allow them to pay less
tax that is just unfair and that i think
is why people are so angry about what's
been happening and also the fact that
they've just not been transparent about
it when there could have been conflicts
of interest in place as well well we all
but um what everybody acknowledges is
that what she has done is perfectly
lawful uh as far as i understand it lots
of other people do something similar and
you might think that you know it's
ethical to do something different but
that she hasn't actually done anything
wrong and i'm wondering whether labour
has the view
that this
perfectly lawful status should now not
be available to people
well as i said rachel has a review
underway and we have previously proposed
reforms in exactly this area but the
issue now is that actually the ethics
matter if you are part of a household
where you are asking people across the
country to pay more to put taxes up to a
70-year high and everybody across the
country is really feeling the strain i
don't know how people are going to be
managing with the cost of living indeed
and
indeed and i asked mr house about that
but the problem the problem is in place
i think that is a serious problem i i
understand the point but it's quite
difficult to take the complaint
that she should have done something
different if you can't say that you
would make it unlawful
so i don't think that's right i think
that ethics do matter when you're in
government particularly there may be a
conflict of interest here as well so we
don't know for example whether the
chancellor declared a conflict of
interest when he was making decisions on
policies there's some policies reported
that do affect
non-doms people with non-dom status we
also don't know
what the facts are around some of the
reports about whether they've been
beneficiaries from tax havens and we
also don't know
some of the wider issues about why the
chancellor has had a permanent residence
card in the u.s at the same time as
indeed parliament and the member of
indeed and i asked mr mulhouse about
that i'm interrupting you simply because
in order to make sure that you don't
have a conflict of interest sorry i'm
trevor sorry
forgive me i'm interrupting you because
i know that you want to talk about
antisocial behavior and i just wanted to
give you half a minute to to say uh
labor's got a policy out uh today that
to tackle
antisocial behavior by creating
police hubs and so on why not just more
police
we do think that we need more police and
particularly more police out on the beat
in our communities we had huge cuts to
policing which the government has
finally accepted it needs to start to
reverse although there are still fewer
police than there were in 2010 but even
now we're still not seeing the police
back in the neighborhoods it was one of
the most important policies labor had
was to set up neighborhood policing in
our communities to tackle anti-social
behavior we're at a time when crime has
gone up when prosecutions have gone down
and in many communities anti-social
behavior is rife and isn't being dealt
with that's why we want to set up
neighborhood police hubs in communities
in towns right across the country to
bring together the police local council
officers to tackle that anti-social
behavior that is making people's lives a
misery and we pay for it by saying
cancel the royal yacht that neither the
navy nor the royal family want and use
that money to cut crime and anti-social
behavior well i'll give you many more
cops after that uh counseling the royal
yacht and and that's 200 million in one
year it has
i've done some arithmetic it gives you
about
i think 60 police officers
in each police force 43 issues of 43
police forces across england
so the royal yacht funding would fund
the hubs it would fund the centers for
example in castleford in my constituency
we now have we've persuaded the police
and the council to work together to set
up a hub there's another one redbridge
council have been setting them up which
are basically a base for local police
and councils to be officers to be based
in the community rather than to be based
miles away to be based locally in the
community and to work with the community
in hot spots of anti-social behavior and
to set up neighborhood prevention teams
what the conservatives have done is they
just collapsed any of the work on
anti-social behavior we used to have
loads of things going on they pulled
back from it they completely decimated
neighborhood policing we're saying bring
back neighborhood policing and bring
back the action on anti-social behaviour
as well
yvette cooper thank you very much for
your time this morning
thank you